Kid: Last lootbox!
Kid: Yes!
I've been wanting one of the Widowmaker skins.
*Clap clap clap clap*
I've been wanting one of these
That is... that is the best skin.
Oh loot boxes is back as a
Controversy you may remember last year with CSGO Lotto
There was a two youtubers that owned the company of loot crate gambling company
But loot crate is back again on everyone's radar
Thanks to EA
Thank you EA, now loot crate just seems to be
everywhere these days
You know I try and buy a sandwich
Would you like to loot crate the
Ingredients and see what you could get? You could get the legendary mozzarella or perhaps when I go to the public restroom
Would you like to loot crate the toilet paper?
You can get a legendary drop where a man will wipe your anus for you sir
It's it's impeccable or you could just win toilet paper. We need more loot crates I keep telling everyone. There's not enough loot crates
CSGO has it, Overwatch has it, even PUBG has it. So there really should be no surprise that the latest Star Wars Battlefront II
Has loot crate in it. Loot boxes, whatever there called. I am just thrilled
I can't wait to open all those boxes on camera and have an epic freakout over
What's inside
(IT'S FREAKING INAUDIBLE, HOW DO YOU EXPECT ME TO TRANSLATE THAT KID'S WORDS)
Ok come on, what is it gonna be?
What is it gonna be? What is it gonna be?
[Screaming] YES! YES! OH MY GOD! OH MY GOD! OH MY GAWD!
Oh my God! A virtual skin for my k-nifffeee! That is
definitely exciting! Maybe I'm not the right person to criticize loot boxes cause I personally have zero interest in them.
I find them extremely repetitive; boring. I don't see the appeal in
Virtual clothing okay? It just seems like something not that appealing, but EA was sitting down at a meeting
doing their quarterly finances
And trying to brainstorm ideas on how
To get more money. How can we squeeze more money out of our customer? How about we make our own
distribution platform cutting off steam and making the general experience of
accessing our games a giant chore?
Genius! That's genius, but not evil enough. How can we make people pay
£69.99
Instead of £54.99? Well we'll give them the elite edition those idiots will love it, but not evil enough.
What about day 1 dlc?
NOT EVIL ENOUGHHH!
Wha-Wha-Wha What about a season pass?
NOT EVIL ENOUGH!
Ok I got it once they spent £69.99
They'll spend even more on loot boxes
Excellent. Now loot boxes is nothing new and uggggggh
Really all this controversy that started around EA and Star Wars, someone on Reddit
That was testing out the game figured out that since their rewards are no longer based on your skill in the game,
Let's say if you perform really well in the game, it's hardly affected
It's morely based on
How much time you play the game. So if you want to play as Darth Vader in the new Star Wars game
You have to unlock him as a hero and to unlock heroes you do so by purchasing loot boxes
Or you can earn them through, through playing the game seems fair enough
You know you get two options, but someone did some (sick)math and calculated that it took
It'll take you 40 hours of gameplay to unlock one hero(seems fair enough)
And that is cutting out all the loading screens all the time between matches and the fact that you can't buy any other
Loot crate in the meantime. You really have to focus 40 hours
specifically for that chance to get that hero drop or you know you could just pay 20 bucks
I mean it's genius. You know you have people spend this amount of money already
Why not make them spend more needless to say people weren't too
Happy about this. The post went viral on Reddit.
EA then made a response which, you know, was probably the most well crafted well-thought-out response of all time
Which is why it got
20,000 minus points
The most disliked post ever on Reddit.
Congratulations. Let's see what it says
(Reads the EA Post)
By spending 40 hours
(Reads it again)(Am I blocking the words?)
When you pay 64 pounds you get a lot of things, not all of things, but a lot of things
(Reads some crap again)(NoW I aM rEaLlY tRyInG tO cOvEr ThE wOrDs)
Or you can just pay us 20 dollars
Here's a, here's where my opinion just goes out the toilet
I agree that loot boxes are terrible. It's a scummy way of practice, but if you hate them so much
Just don't buy them. Just don't buy them they exist for a reason they exist because people are dumb enough to buy them
Now I understand that the concept is that "Whales"
Pretty much as they're called people just spend an over load amount of money on the game
And that's how they make most of their profit because they really squeeze out an insane amount out of certain consumers
It's not like everyone is buying the loot crate's is actually probably a tenth of players that are actually buying them
But that's enough to justify them existing and it just overall ruin the experience for everyone playing the game
It's not like EA has the best track record. I don't see how anyone is surprised by this
Do you do you not remember how many?
How many DLCs they had for Sims?
Sims Living Large, Sims House Party, Sims Hot Date.These were all treated as
Individual games an expansion packs, and they've been doing this for years, and it's not like the whole practice of gambling isn't or
Buying something and not getting quite what you want is
Has never existed before we practically grow up with it as kids
And maybe it's cuz I'm not the biggest Star Wars fan ever, but basically
EA is holding, holding the franchise hostage is pretty much
Oh man, we're reeaally sorry you don't like our loot crate system guys. We just wanted to game to be fair for everyone
you know
Maybe help players catch up if they can find by buying a couple of loot crate's hmm
If you weren't we could give you names of some other companies that are making Star Wars games. Oh wait
We're the only weapons aren't we? Mmmm, I guess you'll have to buy some loot crate's
Now despite what your opinion on the topic is, the memes
The memes are very fresh, okay? They're veeaary nice. EA's new proposed handheld console.
I really I really appreciate this one: We here at EA. Honestly
do not remember making Battlefront a pay-to-win game. The story has encouraged us to address other things in about our company we
Have loved and had romantic encounters with men throughout our life, and we choose now to live as a gay man.
How brave
How brave Electronic Arts
Now a lot of people got fired back around the whole controversy as well because there was this guy named BiggSean
Claiming to work for EA saying that he got 7 death threats and over
1,600 individual personal attacks. Now I don't know how you calculate that like you can keep up with all of them
And I don't mean to sound insensitive or anything, but if I made a big deal out of any time
I got a death threat on the internet. I wouldn't have time to make videos
It's not the death threats on the internet
Don't mean anything
But that's another topic. Now a lot of game magazines took it upon themselves to use this as an opportunity to point out how
Awful gamers are for criticizing the poor game devs. When it turns out, there's no confirmation that he actually works for EA
Most likely he doesn't work for EA, but at the same time who really fucking cares? At the end of the day,
It's Disney and EA.
Two
large companies.
They're gonna squeeze out as much money as they can. What you can do as a consumer is to not buy into it.
Don't be that brainless Star Wars fanboy(liek me) that has to buy all of them.
Just don't buy this one. Stop buying loot crates, refund your games,  and stop crying.
Seriously. I found that there's a petition
so that the ESRB
would declare loot boxes as gambling which I hundred percent agree with it(me too), is a form of gambling
And it should be rated as such. It blows my mind that people are surprised that EA and
Disney we're somehow trying to squeeze money out of people, like that's never done before.
Buy indie games you have people working passionately
on
their own projects, support them instead.(support A.S.S)
eughhhhhh
We have so many options right now as a gamer. This year was incredible. We got so many great releases(liek A.S.S). Support them instead.
i-it's really not that complicated
Anyway, thank you for watching this video. Do you agree or disagree?
Leave a comment down below, leave a like if you enjoyed watching. One like you could unlock my new loot box system
Where in every video I'm announcing a loot box
Where you could win another video.
Eghueghueghueghue
While finishing up this video, EA Star Wars made another statement, three statements about this thing
I sure hope they get it right this time. This was never our intention.
Sorry, we didn't get this right. We hear you loud and clear, so we're turning off all in-game purchases.
That is fantastic they listened to the community
And they responded. Wait a minute. The ability to purchase crystals in-game will become available at later date.
So basically you're just trying to save the launch and you're gonna add micro-transactions anyway
Congratulations to everyone. Now I know people are gonna be pissed about this, but at the same time
They have a budget to recoup and they had a financial plan in this game. They're gonna have to do it regardless
They can't just give out, It's not a charity. I feel like thi.. everyone loses. Congrats.